he actually [ __ ] did it it's done  tyler1 is challenger in every single  role challenger and adc lightweight  challenger in jungle effortless  challenger in top and mid in the same  damn season [ __ ] easy  mid  challenger in support  and just like the last time he hit  challenger in another role the official  league of legends twitter account gave  him a shout out following it up by  sending him a care package with five  challenger medals i am the goddamn  greatest of all time i mean i deserve  this to be honest and tyler left a  parting message to all the support  players out there before i played  support i said all support players suck  the ones that just suck a little less  climb it's true maybe now tyler1 can  finally play some variety games  you me